oh lady mechanic one big family one big
sister would
and we love our hands to be dirty our
fingers to be dirty we are together and
we are fixing cars around the world
all right make sure you do your you have
your homework done
i need to see the papers
all right then good luck my name is
sandra aguerbo
i'm the first female mechanic in nigeria
and the founder of the lady mechanic
initiative i've been a mechanic for 32
years
and i've been running my own garage
for 22 years now so that is the way it
works the lady mechanic initiative is
working with the vulnerable group
the ex-commercial sex workers
this could drop out
married women wants to acquire skill
they are like there's no more hope in my
life i said to them you know what you
have got a lot of hope i'm going to help
you build that hope i'm in here she has
five children and she's a mechanic
amazing
because they are vulnerable they don't
have money they are from poor background
so they don't pay to lend and we do all
this from the funders funders pay their
stipend pay for their lecture overall
and my training is just free of charge
you want to be able to help other women
as well
now we've been able to empower graduated
by a thousand female mechanics in
nigeria in five states
being the first female mechanic in
nigeria is not afraid of roses
may have been there from generation to
generation
fixing cars
when i came in it was like excuse me are
you okay or you need to see a doctor
but no i knew what i was doing but for
me to become the first female mechanic
in nigeria i had to work five times
other than the way the men would walk
to prove myself many people they don't
know me by my name is lady mechanic
everywhere i go
now a lot of guests wants to come to
nigeria to learn
how to fix cars
it's the best job in the world for any
woman i see
you